somewhere underneath this convoy of
tractors and sleds is a lake it sits
under 800 meters of Antarctic ice and
it's probably one of the most isolated
bodies of water on earth a team of
scientists traveled there hoping to
drill into it and I was lucky enough to
go along with him it took them two weeks
to tow their gear out to the drill site
during that time they passed over five
meter crevasses with names like personal
space and [ __ ] they had been
meticulously mapped and bulldozed full
of snow spending time in the flat
landscape of the ice leaves her senses
exquisitely tuned to even tiny changes
in the vertical I remember one time
riding a snowmobile zooming down what
felt like an endless Hill for half an
hour but when I checked my altimeter we
had only dropped four meters drilling
through 800 meters of ice is no simple
matter really nothing is in Antarctica I
sat for hours with the ice drillers as
they board into the glacier this is
Dennis dueling the lead driller looking
kind of actually worried that a camera
has revealed a hole that has branched
into two and this would hold up the
drilling for more than a day because the
scientists were searching for life in
the lake
we had to wear sterile suits to avoid
contaminating the samples those suits
had a way of transforming even the most
virile person into a caricature with a
hunched back and a voluminous about
crack running all the way up to the
shoulder blades
no one knew when they would break into
the lake and determine not to miss that
moment I stayed up for around-the-clock
for four days sleeping only a couple
hours at a time in my tent one morning
the crackle of handheld radio woke me
from a two-hour nap I grabbed a Nalgene
bottle already heavy and frosted over
with a quarter liter or so a frozen
urine Pete's more into it and rushed
over to watch as the lake was finally
pierced I watched as a video camera
that's the black thing on the left was a
lower down a hole into the lake to
confirm that we had reached it 17 of us
watched for a couple of hours as it
inched down the icy hole it was kind of
like a corrugated intestine people were
nervous since we had already had two
false alarms and everyone cheered when
the camera finally plunged into brown
muck at the bottom as mud was raised
from the lake dark glops of it spattered
onto the snow this stuff hadn't seen the
light of day and maybe as long as a
million years and I picked some up and
it was kind of scratchy like what's
cement it was surprising because it
looked really smooth when you looked at
it it was like holding something from
another planet and I think everybody
wanted to touch it for that reason
people even drew lions on their face
with it I watched a paleontologist slip
some under a microscope we saw fragments
of diatoms shells in there
they were signs of life from millions of
years ago and proof that they had found
what they were looking for it was one of
the many moments of this whole trip that
I'll remember for the rest of my life